tous
je le sens qu'elle peut lequel j'ai le
sang qui bouche de sortie tout
bush il y avait des signes qui ne
trompent
rare de le jour dès trouver un homme qui
ne trompent pas tu m'a tapé dans l'oeil
j'aurais perdu la vue sap et dans le
neuf gens répètent du marais tu as donné
de l'amour à ma plume
moi qui suis si tueur d'habitude j'en ai
perdu une amertume plonger dans ton
coeur devenu une évidence sur ton corps
immense du fredonner un air pur que gide
ans décide où tu avais tout pompe l'air
tout pour que je tombe lui aussi tout
bon père quand j'y pense jean pierre
aubert vigilance et c'est ce silence ici
me rappelle ta présence des sorties d'où
toi et des valeurs des mourants mal être
mais momo mal-aimé malheur des gestes
lents qu'ils de langage à zeste de
landes et je restais là son empire de
nos voyages sans longueur notre histoire
n'est pas comme la leur
autre valeur de l'offre s'est éteinte
avant le
j'ai le sang qui bouche kirk et boum ça
d'amour trop tard beauté sortie de toi
et ta belle bouche
je voulais parler mais j'en ai perdu la
voix faut dire que ton amour n'était pas
très dur à voir je te disais un jour on
fera des enfants début de toi fin d'un
fonds story petit mais m'en plains tu
disais je suis droit parce que mon fils
doit l'être
et puis j'ai la foi parce que ma fille
doit l'être tu me parlais religions et
croyances collision entre illogisme et
clairvoyance ainsi je t'ai donné mon
coeur mon corps est dans mon camp tu as
touché sans rancoeur une femme pour cinq
minutes de bon temps t'as foutu en l'air
deux ans de vie commune d'aflou sommer
moi qui suis pourtant sans que tu avais
le pouvoir dans ton [ __ ] tu voulais
tout avoir et des conquêtes surtout son
butin en touchant cette femme tu m'a
touché ans il ton amour et des
moustiques manqué rêvait que de l'office
tu m'en faire une histoire sans fin
aujourd'hui je sais que l'amour on n'est
pas une histoire sans fin
prenez garde ce sentiment qui étouffe
moi je pense ils revivent
mais j'avais perdu mon souffle
à